MORGAN MCLEAN: Hi.
Welcome to "Cloud OnAir"
live from Seattle.
We host webinars every Tuesday.
My name's Morgan McLean.
I'm the product manager for
our Stackdriver APM products.
And today I'm going
to tell you how
to make your apps fast and
reliable with Stackdriver APM.
You can ask questions anytime.
And we'll do a Q&A
session at the end.
So as I mentioned, we're talking
about Stackdriver APM today.
It's the tools that
we offer that'll
allow the next wave
of service developers
to manage their apps as
reliably and performantly
as we do at Google.
Stackdriver APM is composed
of three products, Stackdriver
Profiler, Stackdriver Debugger,
and Stackdriver Trace.
I'll go and do an
overview of these products
in a few minutes, and
then we'll do a live demo.
As I mentioned before,
these are the tools
that unlock the same
methodologies that we've
honed at Google for
years to our customers
and to the broader market.
As you may know, Google's
been an extremely large
microservices operator
for almost a decade now,
and we've developed a lot of
our own methodologies, tools,
and techniques that we now
want to share with our cloud
customers to make
them more successful.
Stackdriver APM can be used on
apps anywhere, not just those
running on GCP.
So you've probably heard of
the Stackdriver brand before.
It's been around for
some time, particularly
with our monitoring product.
Stackdriver is
the suite of tools
that we offer to customers
to improve their development
experience on the
Google Cloud Platform.
Stackdriver Monitoring is what's
most well-known generally.
It was acquired a few
years ago from a startup.
And it's been
brought into Google.
And it has stats and
dashboards and alerts.
We also have Stackdriver
Logging and Error Reporting,
which does logs ingestion and
analysis for our customers,
and can also highlight logs that
appear to be errors, and alert
you on those.
What I'm talking about
is Stackdriver APM.
So this is our suite of
developer-focused tools.
It includes distributed
tracing, production debugging,
and continuous
profiling, all of which
we use at Google every day.
So over the past
few years, Google's
been on a bit of a journey as
a part of its Cloud Platform
initiative.
We've made a lot of headway
and made a lot of waves
by providing parts of
Google infrastructure
to our customers.
Google had to invent a
number of new methodologies,
whether this was high-scale
container orchestration
or new storage
technologies, in order
to operate at extreme scale.
And we've exposed
these to customers.
Some of these are through
open source projects,
like Kubernetes and
Istio, where we've
exposed our internal platform--
Borg is Kubernetes
and Stubby is Istio--
but others are exposing services
through the Cloud Platform.
Examples of this include
Spanner, GKE, and BigQuery.
And there's many, many others.
The next sort of pillar of
what we've been providing
is allowing customers to
emulate our practices.
So the most visible
example of this
is the "Site Reliability
Engineering" bible, which
we published a few years ago.
And there's a second revision
in the works right now.
I think it's being
published pretty soon.
And this allows customers
to use the same SRE
practices and
methodologies that we've
used across our
SRE and dev teams
at Google to keep
ourselves at scale.
Finally, Stackdriver
represents the tools
that we offer to customers.
And so this is the
third pillar that
would allow companies to emulate
a lot of the infrastructure
practices and tools that we have
at Google to operate incredibly
successfully.
So for the past 10,
20 years, developers
have been on a journey.
If you think back
10 or 15 years ago,
as a developer, if you
started at a new company,
it wouldn't be
entirely uncommon,
particularly at smaller
shops, if they didn't
have some form of source control
or bug tracking or code review.
And if you go back a
slightly less amount of time,
maybe five or 10 years ago,
for a services company,
again, it wouldn't
be entirely uncommon
if they didn't have some form of
distributed logging or metrics
or alerts.
It's just those tools were new,
they were sometimes expensive,
and not everywhere
had adopted them yet.
But today, as a
developer, if you
went to a firm of
almost any size
and they didn't have
those, your instinct
would probably be to
walk right out the door,
even if it was on
your first day,
because everybody
in the industry
understands that things
like source control,
bug tracking, metrics, alerting
is incredibly important.
And it's difficult,
if not impossible,
to become a successful
company without these tools
and these methodologies.
We believe that distributed
tracing, production profiling,
and production debugging
are on the cusp
of being this next wave.
With microservices,
in particular,
distributed tracing is
such a powerful concept,
and so are the others,
that in a few years,
our hypothesis is that it
will be very, very difficult
to operate without those.
And indeed, if you look
at companies like Google
or others who
operate at similarly
high-scale and
reliability, you'll
see that tools like
tracing, in particular,
are very, very common.
And so it's our belief that
this is going to trickle down
to all companies of all sizes.
So let's dig into the APM suite.
The first component
is Stackdriver Trace.
This is probably one that
at least some of the viewers
will be more familiar with.
Distributed tracing
over the last year or so
has been making
a lot of inroads.
Stackdriver Trace is a classic
distributed tracing solution.
And what that means
is that it allows
you to view real customer
requests as they come
into your services,
and you can view them
as they propagate across
different services.
So if a request comes into
your front end from service A
and propagates to services
B, C, D, E, and so on,
a distributed trace
captures that.
It's incredibly useful for
understanding service topology.
So understanding how those
services call each other.
And indeed, in an incredibly
complex microservices
deployment, sometimes
it might be the only way
that you know that.
Secondly, traces are incredibly
powerful for latency analysis.
So we use distributed tracing
at Google almost every day
to understand how we
can make Google.com
and our other services
faster and more reliable.
The power of a distributed
trace is that not only does it
show you the hops
that a request takes,
but it also shows you how
long it takes at each hop,
and also which points
were parallelized versus
where you had a bottleneck.
And so it's very,
very powerful when
you want to reduce the latency
of a service, particularly
tail latency.
Google has made a
lot of investments
in this space over the years.
And so you may have heard
of something called Dapper.
Dapper was a distributed
tracing solution
that we created at
Google a long time ago.
We published a white paper
on it, I believe, in 2010.
And in fact, if you look at
many other distributed tracing
solutions that are available
on the market, many of them
will reference that white paper
as being what sort of gave them
the idea for building this.
And we're exposing
Dapper to our customers
through Stackdriver Trace.
The next is
Stackdriver Profiling.
This is actually the newest
entrant to our APM suite.
Stackdriver Profiler is
a continuous statistical
profiler.
So it's meant to be
run in production,
much like our other
tools, continually.
It's not a profiler that you
turn on at certain points.
And it's not a profiler that
hinders your performance
at all.
Continuous profiling
is very powerful.
It allows you to understand
the call patterns of your app
in production, like,
the actual function call
patterns within your code
as opposed to a trace, which
shows you, generally,
service call patterns.
And it's very powerful for
understanding how much CPU
and memory every function uses.
If anyone watching is a
Microsoft developer, which
I imagine many of
you are, you might
understand that profiling,
much like debugging,
which we're going to
talk about in a minute,
is generally something that you
do for client app development.
It's very powerful.
It's very useful.
But when you've moved to
web services, particularly
microservices, it's
very difficult.
With Stackdriver Profiler,
we give you this data
and allow you to discover
where time's being spent,
where memory is being spent.
And so it's very powerful
for general performance
improvements as well
as reducing your costs.
And we use the same technology
behind this at Google every day
across almost all of
our biggest services.
Finally, we have Stackdriver
Debugger, which in some ways
is probably the most magical
of these three tools.
Stackdriver Debugger is
a production debugger
that's safe for use in
production environments
with real customer traffic
going through them.
Rather than creating
traditional breakpoints,
it creates what
we call snapshots,
which are effectively
breakpoints except they
don't halt execution.
So you can lay them down in our
very simple IDE-like interface
that shows your code.
When they get triggered
with real customer traffic
or if you trigger
them yourselves
by mocking a
request, they capture
the local variables
and the call stack,
but they don't halt
execution, which
makes them really, really
powerful for root cause
analysis.
Debugger also has another
feature called Logpoints, which
allows you to add log
statements to your application
across all of its
instances in real time,
so you don't have
to redeploy it.
So again, really powerful
root cause analysis tools.
And let's just double-click
on these for a second.
So all of these services
offer lightweight open source
instrumentation.
So for tracing and
for app-level metrics,
our instrumentation is
done through a project
that we run called
OpenCensus that we're
collaborating on with a
number of other vendors.
And OpenCensus
provides libraries
that you link to
your app that'll
capture traces,
app-level metrics,
and you can also add
your own information
to get sent back to us.
Our remaining products,
so Profiler and Debugger,
also have open source
instrumentation.
It's not part of
OpenCensus, but they're
all open source on GitHub.
And we think this is really
powerful for developers,
because they can understand
how we're actually
interacting with their app.
If, for some reason,
they need to make
a change to the instrumentation,
they can do so and rebuild it.
And it's really easy
to use, because it's
tied in to your
source control system.
So you're not deploying agents
to a VM or updating them there.
You're simply, typically,
linking a library
to your application.
Or for Java, you're referencing
it again as a Java agent.
You can rebuild your app, check
in that change, and deploy it.
And you can roll forward
and back between versions
through source control.
So it's really, really
powerful and really
easy to use for developers.
We support a number
of languages.
So on Trace and Debugger, we
support Java, Go, Node.js,
.NET, Ruby, Python, and PHP.
On Trace, we also support
C++ instrumentation.
Profiler is quite new.
So the amount of
instrumentation is lower.
Right now, we have support
for Java, Go, and Node.js.
And we're building right
now, and hopefully it'll
ship pretty soon,
instrumentation for Python 3.
Profiler is free during
the beta test period.
Debugger is currently free.
And Trace is free up to 2 and
1/2 million spans per month,
which is quite a bit.
We expect most customers to
stay within the free tier.
And so now I'm actually
going to hop to a live demo.
So what I've done is I've taken
a microservices application
actually developed by
Weaveworks called Sock Shop.
And it's available on GitHub.
And it's a really
useful application
for testing out both monitoring
systems and microservices
deployments.
And we've taken
this code, and we've
deployed it to a GKE instance.
And so you can see all
of the services here.
And Sock Shop's a really
great demo for our products
both because it has,
I think, roughly eight
different services written
in different languages,
so it's got three Java
services, three Go
services, and, I think,
two Node.js services,
but it's also useful because
it wasn't written by us.
When you're a vendor,
there's always an incentive
to build a demo that works
with your technologies
and can show off
your golden path.
Sock Shop's really powerful
because it emulates a journey
that many of our
customers will go
on when they're taking
their application,
whether it's running
on-prem or in GCP,
and trying to instrument
it in Stackdriver.
And so it was a great learning
experience for the team,
but also a great demonstration
for our customers for demos
like this to see how our tools
interact with a codebase that
might resemble their own.
So let's dive into
Stackdriver Trace.
This is the main UI
for Stackdriver Trace.
We present captured
requests, or traces,
on a scatterplot-style view.
This is useful for two reasons.
First off, you can get
a general understanding
of the latency profile
of your application
from the scatterplot.
But secondly, it makes it
really easy to acquire traces.
Today, our sampling for
traces-- so we don't trace every
request, we trace a certain
percentage of them--
our sampling is somewhat random.
And so, generally,
as a developer,
you're going to be
interested in traces
that have some kind of
unique characteristic,
whether that's ones that have
high latency, which is what I'm
clicking on in this
case, or traces
that are correlated from error
or some other interesting
event.
And a scatterplot
makes it really easy
to acquire, in particular,
the high latency traces.
And so I'd run a load
test against Sock Shop,
and generated a very high
latency burst of traffic.
In fact, the latency,
at some point,
was up to 40 milliseconds.
And we can use this UI to
quickly acquire some traces.
Now, most of these are
requests to the cart service,
which are fairly simple.
Request goes in.
Something gets
added to the cart.
Response goes back.
But what we'll do
is we'll actually
jump to a request made to
the orders end point, which
generates a really
powerful trace, because it
crosses a number of services
and has some custom annotations.
And as you can see here, we have
a much more verbose, much more
powerful distributed trace.
And so we can click through
this and see metadata
from each component.
These components
are called spans.
You can understand which spans
call each other versus which
are parallel with the
parent-child relationships
that we show here.
But really importantly,
you can see
where this trace became
actually distributed rather
than just being a simple trace.
So you can see, while this trace
originated on the orders end
point, it also
hopped to addresses,
it also then hopped
to the cart service,
and eventually went to
the shipping service.
And so with a classic
tracing system,
you wouldn't be able
to see any of this.
But the distributed
trace allows us
to both understand
the service topology
and also where the
latency was spent.
And so you can imagine,
as a developer,
if you were tasked with
speeding up this service,
you'd probably start looking
around here at the cart service
or further here down in
the shipping service.
Indeed, there's
a async call here
that doesn't appear
to be actually running
asynchronously.
And so you might want
to start with that
for your latency
analysis investigation.
Next, I'm going to show
Stackdriver Debugger.
So as I mentioned,
Stackdriver Debugger
is very similar to a
traditional debugging solution
that you may have
used previously,
whether that's, like, a
standard interactive debugger
in IntelliJ or Visual
Studio, except it's
running in production.
And it's running across
all instances of your app.
You don't have to attach
it to a single instance.
You just open Debugger
and just start working.
And I'm going to show you
some of the functionality.
So we have a function here.
This is the URL handler for
adding a new item to the cart.
We're in the front end service,
which is written in Node.js.
Now, what I'm going to do
is just a simple example.
I'm going to lay down a
new snapshot on this line,
and we're going to look for
the value of customer ID.
So if we go back to
Weaveworks, and we add an item
to our-- or sorry,
not to Weaveworks,
to Sock Shop, and add an item to
our cart, you can see it there.
And we jump to our cart.
Then we can jump to Debug.
And we can see that we've
now captured the snapshot.
Now, in a real production
app with real traffic,
a snapshot without
many conditions
will get triggered
almost instantly.
That's because you'd
be capturing data
from real customer requests.
And if you have
concerns about PII,
we have ways of hiding that
from your developers as well.
And so in this example,
we can see that we've
captured my customer ID here.
And if I wasn't signed
in to the Sock Shop demo,
you'd see a null customer ID.
Another cool thing that
we can do is copy this.
We can actually set
it as a condition.
And we can reapply the
snapshot or apply another one
on the line above.
And we can rerun the request.
And while this
doesn't necessarily
generate an interesting
example, because, of course,
we know my customer
ID, it really
shows off how we have similar
tools, as you can see,
we captured-- similar tools
to traditional debuggers.
So we can use custom
conditions and we
can use expressions
to show the values
of certain specific variables
that you want to capture.
And we also show
the call stack here.
So it's a really
powerful debugging tool,
you can imagine, for
root cause analysis.
You can use this
to find out both
of the state of your system and
if certain control flow state
systems aren't
working as you expect.
The next feature that I
want to show is Logpoints.
So Logpoints allows you
to add log statements
to your application instantly.
And you can add conditions
or use your own log,
just add a custom state.
So what we'll put here is--
we're going to print
out the customer ID.
So first, we're going
to say, OnAir Webinar.
And we'll print out
the customer ID.
And we'll apply this.
And one of the really nice
things about Logpoints
is that it works with
different logging systems.
So in this case, we're
using Stackdriver Logging,
which, as I mentioned before,
is our in-house logging solution
that we offer to GCP customers.
But if you were using another
logging solution or just
capturing logs locally,
Stackdriver Debugger Logpoints
would work fine.
And it's really, really nice.
So we'll add this to the cart.
And that will capture
a log statement.
And this can take-- this isn't
as immediate as a snapshot.
But we start searching
through our logs here.
Sorry.
We're going to say logpoint.
And you can see, we captured
our log statement right here.
And we can view it inside
of the Debugger UI.
So you don't even have to jump
between Debugger and Logging
when you're performing these
kinds of investigations.
It's really, really nice.
Finally, we're jumping
to Stackdriver Profiler.
Now, I admit this is a
different GCP project.
We have one that generates
really nice profiles
and is great for demos.
So I've switched to that.
And the code in this app
that we're profiling,
it's an application that
constantly zips and unzips
a file.
So it's basically just
compressing and decompressing
data continually.
And so it generates a
really nice flame graph
as opposed to a demo app that
gets very little service.
What you can see here
is the flame graph
that we generate from
capturing those profiles.
On the vertical
axis, you can see
the different names
of functions and you
can see their hierarchy.
So in this case,
[INAUDIBLE] once,
which calls
writer.write, and so on.
And on the horizontal axis,
you can see the amount
of the resource being consumed.
In this case, we're
looking at CPU time.
But Profiler also supports heap
profiling on languages other
than Java-- we're
working on Java,
there's some restrictions
from the JVM--
as well as thread and
contention profiling.
And as I mentioned
before, this is
a continuous
statistical profiler.
So we have effectively
no performance impact
on your application.
It runs always in
the background.
So you can capture real data.
But the way we do this is
by having the Profiler agent
generally run on a maximum
of one instance at a time,
and only take samples
every so often.
So we'll capture profiling
data for an hour or a day
or a week or longer,
and then we'll
take the aggregation of that
and build this flame graph.
So it gives you a really
good view into general system
performance.
So you can see in this
example on the flame graph,
if you were a developer who
had been tasked with either
improving the performance of
this application or reducing
its cost, you'd probably
be interested in this
compressor.deflate function,
and that's because it takes up
a lot of horizontal area,
just like the ones above it,
but its children don't.
And so it has a very high,
what we call, self time.
In this case, 53% of the CPU is
being consumed by this function
and not by its children.
And as a developer, you'd be
very, very interested in that.
Now, if you know
about compression,
then you probably know
the deflate process
will take a while.
That might be expected.
But we've had customers
who've had examples
where this was a function they
didn't expect it to be, like,
a regular expression
or something else,
where a significant percentage,
not 50% or anything like that,
was consumed by code
that should not have
been consuming that much CPU.
And as a developer,
you can very quickly
see that from the flame graph.
We had a number of customers
in the alpha report
that with about roughly one
hour of work with Profiler,
they saved about 10%
off their bill, which
is incredibly powerful.
And if you can imagine operating
at extremely high-scale,
like some of these groups,
it's a lot of money.
If you were tasked with
doing a micro optimization
or improving a small part
of the system performance,
you can also just click on
your area, we'll zoom in,
and you can then
get a better view
of where your CPU time or memory
or other data is being spent.
So really, really powerful.
Profiler is quite new.
We have some new
features that will
be coming out fairly shortly,
including what we're calling--
we don't really have
a name for it yet,
but what we're calling sort of
weighted profiling, where we're
going to give a higher
weight to profiles
that are captured at periods
of high CPU or resource
consumption.
So you can get a
better view of how
your system's performing in
the worst case as opposed
to the average case.
And so that makes it more
powerful as a solution
to detect tail latency.
We also have some
integrations that are
pending with Stackdriver Trace.
So let's hop back
to our presentation.
So to recap over what
we just went through,
because I know it was
quite a bit, we start,
we have Stackdriver Debugger.
Debugger snapshots and
dynamic log statements
remove a lot of steps from your
root cause analysis cycles.
So you can imagine that
snapshots or laying down
logpoints would replace your
traditional debugging steps
that you might have today.
At a lot of companies when
there's a code error, what they
have to do is, when they
don't know where it is,
they add log statements
to their code.
They then redeploy their app
with the error still in tow,
because they don't
know where it is
and they don't
know how to fix it.
Once the app is redeployed and
they look at the [INAUDIBLE]
log statements,
hopefully it tells them
where the code error was
or what the problem was.
But it might not
always, and then you
have to redo that
steps again and again.
And if you have a
slow deployment cycle,
that takes a long time.
And so Debugger reduces
this to almost zero.
You can use snapshots to
find those issues to find out
if certain if statements or
loops are being triggered,
if things are not operating
the way you expect them to be,
without having to
redeploy your app.
And you can you do it across
all of the instances of your app
seamlessly.
So no more attaching a
debugger, no more testing
in a non-production environment.
So really, really powerful.
We use this at
Google all the time.
It's a pretty magical
feature that we wanted
to expose to our customers.
Next we have Profiler, which
operates at extreme scale
and isn't limited to
analyzing single transactions.
One of the biggest uses that
we've seen with customers
is both cost reduction, but
also finding slow memory leaks.
And because it operates
over a long time
and because you can
change those time filters,
by dragging your
view through time,
you can actually see if
certain functions are now
consuming more and more
memory, which imply
that there's a leak there.
We have a number of
new features coming
to Profiler throughout
the rest of the year.
And we're really excited
to see where it goes.
Finally, we have
Stackdriver Trace.
Distributed tracing
for the last few years
has become generally
better understood
by a lot of our customers and
indeed the industry at large.
But tracing tools tend to be
either expensive or difficult
to adopt.
There are some open source
solutions in this space.
Generally, deploying your
own can be quite challenging.
And a lot of the paid
solutions are quite costly.
Stackdriver Trace isn't.
It's easy to get started with.
For most customers,
it's effectively free.
And it can give you deep insight
into how your service topology
works and also how to reduce
latency in your application.
I want to touch on
instrumentation one more time.
So all of our instrumentation
is Apache-licensed and open
source, and it's on GitHub.
All of it-- or we generally--
not always the case
with Debugger, because
it's not quite as useful.
But we generally expose
APIs that developers can use
to capture your custom data.
Now, what I mean by
that is for tracing,
you can create your own spans.
You can add
annotations to spans.
So in the demo that I just
did, some of those spans
didn't necessarily
represent RPCs or requests
that went to other services.
They were, rather,
created by the developer
to track what they thought
were long-running processes.
And for Profiler,
we also, similarly,
have APIs that you can use
to capture custom data.
For Debugger, on some
of the languages,
we have APIs that allow you to
arbitrarily capture a snapshot.
Our traces and app-level metrics
are captured via a project
that we call OpenCensus
that we're collaborating on
with other vendors.
OpenCensus effectively
automatically captures traces,
allows you to annotate them,
captures app-level metrics,
and then will send them to
the back end of your choice.
And Stackdriver is one
of those back ends.
But we also support Prometheus,
Zipkin, and a number of others.
I mentioned that we had a alpha
test of Stackdriver Profiler.
And so one of the groups that
joined the alpha test with us
was Snapchat.
And so they had a lot of
success with Profiler.
They were able to
find areas in the code
where they had been consuming
more CPU than they expected.
So it was performing more
slowly or costing more money
than they had desired.
And they used Profiler
to both highlight those,
because they didn't
know about them,
and also to then optimize them.
And so they were happy
enough that they provided us
with a nice quote that I'm
able to share with you here.
But Snap was certainly
not the only participants
in this alpha.
I know at Google,
at GCP, we like
to talk about Snapchat
a lot in particular.
We had a number of companies.
And as I mentioned before,
we heard from a number
of customers that they--
with roughly one hour
of time, and they
were able to shave about
10% off of their bill.
So let's sort of summarize
what we've talked about.
So Stackdriver APM is
an essential toolkit
for the next wave of developers.
It unlocks the methodologies
and the tools and techniques
that we've used at Google
over the past decade
to operate at extreme
scale and to ship codes
safely and quickly.
And it provides these to
customers around the world.
These customers might
be running on GCP.
They might be running on-prem.
They might not even use some
of our services, and that's OK.
We want them to use
Stackdriver APM.
We're really excited and really
proud of the functionality
that it provides.
Developers can use these tools
generally on web services,
but also on other things,
their slow-running processes.
And it really is going to
just provide a lot of insight
and a lot of
confidence, I think,
to engineering organizations
about their ability
to understand what
their service is doing
and their ability to
ship code rapidly.
As I mentioned before, it works
on services hosted anywhere,
whether that's any other
cloud or on-premises.
And we're pretty
excited about it.
All right, so that wraps
up the presentation.
We're going to hop to
Q&A in a few minutes.
Thank you very much.
All right, we're back!
So we gathered some
questions from the audience.
And I'm going to answer these.
The first question is, can I
debug Node.js or Angular code
running on my local
machine, like my laptop?
How can different reports help
in understanding the issues?
So I'm going to
guess that by debug,
you mean Stackdriver Debugger.
And, yes, you can
use it to debug code
that's running locally
or anywhere else.
We've used it both internally
at Google and other places
where, in fact, the
instrumentation is
running on someone's laptop.
One of the other
things that I forgot
to mention during
the demo is that you
can also-- to view
the source code,
you have to pull it in
from another source, sort
of syncing it from another
source to pull it in.
And so if your code is stored
on GitHub, on Bitbucket,
on GitHub Enterprise, on
GitLab, or the Google Cloud
repositories, you can
just use your credentials
to automatically
make the code show up
in Stackdriver Debugger.
The other thing you can do for
this laptop debugging scenario,
where you might not want to
be storing the code elsewhere
or because you're just doing
something simply locally is you
can-- and if we can
just cut to my screen--
in the Debugger, you can go
to [INAUDIBLE] source code UI,
and you can actually
select Local Files.
And what this allows you to do
is actually pull in source code
that's stored locally
from your machine.
This is useful for that
local debugging scenario
that you're asking about.
But this is also
useful when you've
made edits that are
running elsewhere,
not on your primary
service, or when you know
the exact version of code
that's being deployed
and you want to debug it.
So you're not forced to
pull it in through GitHub
or other sources.
Another interesting
thing about this feature
is that we actually don't
save your code to Google.
It simply syncs locally
to your browser.
Never gets sent to us.
And so if you have any
security concerns or concerns
about Google accessing your
code, you don't need to worry.
It's all pulled in just
locally to your browser.
Never gets transmitted.
The next question
is about Profiler.
The question is, is
Python on the roadmap?
If so, which quarter?
Same question for Scala.
So Python is actually
already being worked on.
Right now we're working
on Python 3 support.
We plan on supporting Python 3.
We're debating
Python 2 right now.
If you have opinions
about supporting Python 2,
please let us know on the
Cloud Insiders mailing list
or through in-app feedback.
But, yes, Python's
on the roadmap.
My understanding is it's going
to ship within the next two
months.
Don't quote me on that.
But that's my understanding.
And that will be Python
support for VMs and containers.
So that includes the
Google Compute Engine,
Google Kubernetes Engine,
or VMs or containers
running elsewhere.
We're going to revisit the
support [INAUDIBLE] standard
coming up soon.
We know that Python's incredibly
popular there as well.
Same question for Scala.
I'm not certain about that.
I'd say I have to
get back to you,
but I don't actually
know how to reach you.
But Scala, I don't know.
I know that Debugger
supports Scala.
But I'm not certain if
Profiler does or does not.
It ties into the JVM
via the agent interface.
So I suspect it might just work.
But I can't speak
with confidence.
I apologize.
The next question.
What's this OpenCensus thing
that I keep hearing about?
How's that related to this?
How does OpenTracing relate?
That's a very good question.
So OpenCensus, as I mentioned
during the presentation,
is an instrumentation
project for tracing
and for app-level
metrics and tags
that we're participating on
with a number of other vendors.
OpenCensus actually
ties back to a project
at Google called Census.
And we probably could
have gotten clever
with the open source name.
But whatever.
And Census, it's a library
that's automatically
attached to every job
running at Google,
so every container
that automatically captures
traces and metrics,
and performs the
appropriate correlations.
OpenCensus is just our
externalized version of this.
We've been really
successful internally.
We want to bring those same
benefits to the community.
And part of the reason that
we've been participating
with other vendors is that
tracing instrumentation
can be very difficult.
One of the challenges
of distributed
tracing is that you
want to be able to automatically
propagate contexts,
so like a trace ID, for
example, from incoming
to outgoing requests, and
do that across services.
This is somewhat easier inside
of a company like Google,
where we generally use the
same libraries and same APIs.
But in the external world,
this is challenging,
because you need to
support every language
that your developers use, so
we target eight for OpenCensus,
as well as every single web
framework, RPC framework,
storage library, and so on.
So you can generate
both interesting traces
or, at a minimum,
propagate context.
This becomes very difficult.
It's very expensive for vendors
to do this, which
is why we kicked off
this effort with the community
and with other vendors
to work together on
building these libraries.
And to be clear, OpenCensus
is a set of libraries.
So each library contains
the instrumentation,
so those hooks
into web framework,
storage clients, et cetera.
It contains APIs that you
can use to manually interact
with traces and metrics, and
then it contains exporters,
which will send these back to
either Stackdriver or SignalFx
or whatever back end
that you're using.
And so that's sort of leading
into this next question
about OpenTracing, and that's
sort of the big difference.
OpenTracing provides
a generalized API
for interacting with
traces specifically.
OpenCensus provides not just
APIs, but instrumentation
and an implementation that allow
developers to operate on these.
The APIs for OpenTracing
and OpenCensus
are slightly different.
For tracing,
obviously, OpenCensus
has many more APIs for metrics
and stats and other things.
They differ very slightly.
We've had some meetings with the
OpenTracing group about maybe
sort of alleviating that.
But at a minimum, I
think we've already
taken a pull request
that adds sort
of a supplemental
OpenTracing API
to OpenCensus if you have any
OpenTracing instrumentation.
So if you've already made
investments in OpenTracing,
that'll still work
on OpenCensus.
All right.
Next question.
For Profiler, is there some
smart profiler concepts
that highlights likely
problem areas, a la ML,
for inspection for a developer
or a trained production support
engineer?
That is another great question.
So Profiler, as I
mentioned, is quite new.
While we've been using it for
some time inside of Google,
it's only just
reached beta state,
I think, two months ago
for external customers
through Stackdriver Profiler.
And so we're adding a ton
of features as we speak.
So if I think about the
concept of smart profiling,
I talked about the weighted
profiling during the demo.
And so what this
will do is allow you
to more selectively [INAUDIBLE]
your application when
it's running into CPU
or memory problems.
So you'll get a more effective
flame graph out of that
that you can use to
perform your own analysis.
And that's really
useful when you're
investigating poor performance
as opposed to just general cost
reduction.
And so that's a sort of
smart profiler concept--
though it doesn't use ML--
that we're adding to
the product as we speak.
If I think longer-term,
there's a lot
of integrations we have
planned between Stackdriver
Profiler and Stackdriver Trace.
In particular, this will make
tail latency analysis really,
really powerful.
So trying to reduce the
latency in the 95th percentile
case or 99th percentile case.
And when I think
even longer-term,
that's when things like
ML come into the picture.
And it's certainly not just
for Profiler, but in general,
just using ML on all of the
signals that we collect,
whether those be traces,
metrics, profiles, and so on.
And so we will be making
investments in that.
And we have some people
already thinking about this.
But Profiler's in an
early enough state
that we're mostly focused
on just adding features
that developers can
use on their own
rather than having computers
solve it for them to identify
places of poor performance
or identify areas
where they can improve the
speed of their application.
We have some other similar
really clever features
coming to Stackdriver Trace.
So as I mentioned
during the presentation,
we do random sampling
for requests today.
And so this is useful, because
it gives you a good profile
of the latency of your app.
But one of the challenges
is that, of course,
most of the requests
that you capture
might not be interesting.
We're going to switch
that pretty soon
to what we're calling
deferred sampling,
so we can sample based
on accumulative latency
or the presence of
errors, which will also
improve the sampling for trace.
Much like I mentioned we're
investing in smart profiling
features, we're making
these investments
to make tracing
much more powerful
and effectively just a smarter
distributed tracing system.
And those features are being
added to the OpenCensus
project, so that not
just Stackdriver,
but other vendors can
benefit from them as well.
Next question.
I don't use Stackdriver today.
How hard is it to
get started with APM?
How long does it take
for my developers
to go from zero
to ready to debug?
That's a good question.
So Stackdriver is
really, really easy
to get started with,
particularly Stackdriver APM.
So today-- I can
actually speak to this
very directly, as I instrumented
the Sock Shop service
that you saw during the demo.
If you're starting from
scratch, so you've never
used any kind of APM or tracing
or profiling system before,
what you do is you get
the OpenCensus libraries.
You link those to your app.
You get the one for
the correct language.
In most languages, that
will mean that once
you do that, you'll get
traces and app-level
metrics automatically.
In some languages,
particularly Java,
you have to do a small
amount of work just
to plumb through
the correlation.
We have a lot of hooks
that make it easy.
But we can't do it
fully automatically,
particularly if you're
crossing thread boundaries.
So you do a bit of work to
get trace correlation working.
Even if you don't do that,
you'll still get the metrics.
Then you can link the
Profiler and Debugger agents
to your application.
So in Java, that's a
Java agent that you put
in your Java [INAUDIBLE] path.
In other languages,
it's typically
just a library you link
to your code and redeploy.
If you're running
on GCP, for example,
if you're running on GKE, as
with this demo, that's all
you need to do.
You don't need to supply
credentials or anything else.
We pick those up automatically.
And so with a few
minutes of work,
you can get most of
these tools or if not all
of these tools
working perfectly.
If you're running
on-premises, you'll
need to supply your service
account credentials, which
I think you can do via
environment variables
or just via you can embed
them directly in your code.
You can do that, and then
your APM instrumentation
will start responding
back to us.
The second part of
the question was
how long it'll take
developers to go
from zero to ready to debug.
These tools are very intuitive.
If you think of the UI that
we have for Stackdriver Trace
or Stackdriver Debugger, this--
Debugger, in particular, we
try and emulate a classic IDE
interface that you've used.
If you use really
any text editor,
but in particular,
IntelliJ or Visual Studio,
which have built-in debugging,
we try and emulate that.
We found that for Debugger,
like, engineers just
get it almost instantly.
It's exactly what
they're used to.
It works exactly as
you would expect.
And there's no need to even
attach to particular instances.
So we found that teams
are able to get started
with this really quickly.
We're doing a lot of
work later this year
to better integrate
these products, and so
to provide a single
seamless UI, where
you can jump between traces,
errors, snapshots, and so on.
That should make it even easier
for people to get started.
But in its current
implementation,
I think Stackdriver
APM is pretty easy
to get started with.
All right.
So that wraps up our
list of questions.
I think we're all done.
So thank you very
much for watching.
And I'll see you soon.
Bye.